in your writing what is it that
generates ideas for you is it people
watching is something that happens to
you in your own life
in my writing the ideas often come from
my dad because my screen writing partner
so that's great you know I don't
necessarily have to come up with the
germ of the idea a lot of times although
I have you know in our partnership as
years have gone on but with with
screenwriting yes i would say in
screenwriting i come up with the ideas
some of the time in terms of the core
idea of the script and you know my
partner comes up with them the rest of
the time so that's in terms of the basic
idea in terms of songwriting that's
usually from emotional dress of some
kind i would say you know if i'm having
like a wonderful day then great like
just highs and lows of normal emotion
that's more from real life I find a lot
of times and that's like I guess my way
of working through whatever I'm feeling
is let me just write a song about
you know whereas with screenwriting it's
a bit more disciplined because it's
about what the characters are feeling
under those circumstances that are you
know sometimes will write a historical
historically based piece and that's that
set in stone what what those people were
going through you know and you just try
to
like an actor put yourself in in what
that would be like and how you would
react and how they must have felt at the
time to the best of your ability you
know so writing a cerebral for you
whereas music is more emotional I think
so yeah there was a time with music that
I felt oh this is so personal like some
of the things I'm saying the one the one
thing that you get though as as the
songwriter is no one ever knows which
songs are about your personal
experiences and which ones are ones you
just wrote because you had an idea and I
kind of like people not knowing that
because and I think some songs are so
personal that they would think that
they're about me like are my personal
life or something and I know that
they're not you know you infuse it I
suppose with your experience but but
they're actually not about my life where
some of them are directly out of my room
so um yeah I don't know I guess I like I
like that's the one piece like I thing
as an actor you have you're asked to
bare your soul for example on stage or
on screen whatever it is but the one
thing that you have is the mask which is
the character and you can say
oh that wasn't me I was acting you know
that's that's not me even though you
could have done a great job and really
lived it so people do think she's
probably like that you know that's why
we think celebrities are like this one
cared oh he's probably like that in real
life he might just be a wonderful Hector
you don't know but in in the songwriting
I think the mask is the fact that and
nobody knows which songs were about me
or weren't and I think that I don't know
I guess I'm kind of private in that way
i don't necessarily want people to know
which ones are about my life and which
ones all right that's so that's so
private I mean you're bearing here your
your thoughts thoughts that came from
you if you were the songwriter you know
where this is exactly how I felt
actually like my heart was completely
broken and I felt abandoned and that's
just a lot to put out there and to own
you know and it's what it's what
inevitably resonates with people because
people have felt that way and sometimes
they'll own that to you when they say oh
I really love this song I totally love
that song and then you're like oh if you
love that song you've probably been
through that and and in the quiet of my
room I'm like yeah I went through that
too you know so it's a nice way to
connect with people but I don't know
there's kind of a nice
thing to have a little theoretical
distance from it where you get the
little little bit of privacy where
people don't know which ones are
actually about you I don't know why I
like that but I just sort of do
you